décidément ce sont les faits divers et
leurs conséquences qui ont la vedette
aujourd'hui ce matin a commencé à
marseille le procès de charles ranucci
accusé d'avoir enlevé une petite fille
au mois de juin 1974 d'une petite fille
qui a été retrouvée assassinée de quinze
coups de couteau sur l'un des portiques
de pierres blanches de la façade du
palais de justice d'aix
il y a marqué en gros ce raid bleu oui à
la peine de mort est dans la salle
d'assises une foule tasser pour
l'instant silencieuse semble contenir
ses cris de haine dans ces conditions
c'est l'honneur du barreau que le
défendre une cause fallait dire une tête
qui paraît perdue d'autant que christian
ranucci agressif arrogante et et adopte
un système de défense qui contribue à
aiguiser l'atmosphère en somme il
rejette tout il dit j'ai été torturé par
les policiers alors j'ai avoué tout ce
qu'ils ont voulu
et il ajoute j'étais ivre je ne me
souviens de rien malheureusement les
précisions de ses aveux et l'examen des
experts contredisent ses protestations
d'innocence alors il reste le corps
d'une fillette transpercé de coups de
couteau et un homme dont le geste défie
la raison et c'est là que le procès des
ex prend une autre dimension ranucci
n'est pas fou intelligent d'une bonne
culture pas de drogue pas d'alcool pas
de déviation mental même pas ce fameux x
chromosome supplémentaire dont on dit
que c'est la fatalité du crime
christian ranucci et simplement doté si
l'on peut dire d'une émotivité excessive
d'une sexualité hésitante une
personnalité floue et écrasé par l'image
d'une mère possessive ranucci a tué sans
l'avoir prévu sans l'avoir désiré sans
en avoir besoin
il s'est écrié tout à l'heure en parlant
de l'enfant nos routes se sont croisées
je ne la connaissais pas je n'y peux
rien personne ne l'a cru
dramatique accident
un procès qui s'achève aux asémistes aix
en provence dans la plus grande
incertitude le procès de christian
ranucci 21 ans accusé du rapt et de
l'assassinât d'une fillette de 8 ans
maria dolores tremble quoique
circonstances de ce drame ne soit pas
tout à fait identiques
on ne peut évidemment éviter de faire un
rapprochement avec le rapt et
l'assassinât de philippe bertrand
ce petit garçon de 3 et effectivement
les personnalités les deux accusés ont
des points communs
rien dans leur famille dans leur fille
ne semblait prédestiner à accomplir avec
une voix calme avec le fonds d'actions
de provence qui contredit les nous
quittons un village de grand père celui
liant à l'enfant l'avocat général
viala les panneaux modou table qui
captivent l'attention 4,4 fois la rue
qui la peine de mort contre qui sera ni
l'homme dans son dos semblait se passer
dehors la foule s'épaississait formé de
curieux d'avis que partielle je n'ai
jamais vu une défense des avocats
repousser autant la limite de leurs
moyens et de leurs convictions ils ont
bien fait leur métier
il voulait créer le doute c'est à dire
prévenu nous faire grandir cette idée de
mesures de calme dans la paix la
sérénité de la justice une tâche énorme
devant la collection que tous avaient de
la culpabilité du social je vends aussi
le fait qu'il ne faut pas dissimuler de
l'homme à être accusé de rap de marque
enfin semblé aux yeux de la troupe
porter le visage d'autres mieux
supporter le poids d'autres crimes
[ __ ] le projet de christian ranucci
est venue rappeler nous rappeler que le
crime n'est pas forcément le château
marmont tous les crimes et une tentation
de tous les jours même pour un homme
si nous laissions pas de cet enfant
il a fait tout de même lorsque quelque
chose c'est d'être à cannes son esprit
l'espace d'un instant ce qui peut nous
arriver à chacun
la peur ou de l'intérêt le projet qu au
delà de l'homme devenu un exemple nous
rappelle contre la raison et le crime ne
se trouvent souvent de la volonté
la codah cela courdès
bouches du rhône a condamné à mort
christian ranucci pour avoir enlevé et
assassiné de quinze coups de couteau une
petite fille maria dolorès rambla notre
envoyé spécial à aix pour le faire
l'homme est étrangement seul lorsque
debout entre deux gardes qui guette la
défaillance ou pire l'incident lorsqu'il
entend les mots la cour et les jurés
vous condamne à la peine de mort le mot
mort semble se répéter dans la salle
dans les couloirs
dehors sur le perron où les gens
attendent christian ranucci n'a rien dit
n'a rien fait il est resté de glace
comme figé par l'annoncé d'un avenir si
l'on peut dire qu'il repoussait de toute
certitude depuis de longs mois
pas un cri non plus dans la salle où un
souffle de dignité est finalement passé
un homme s'est effondré un peu plus le
père de l'enfant morte qui a sans doute
réalisé ce soir que rien même ceux qui
le souhaitaient depuis longtemps ne
calmera sa douleur une femme partage
cette souffrance la mère de christian
ranucci eu d'autres victimes
finalement et jurés sont sortis à parent
redescendu dans la foule anonyme dont il
était le symbole conscient
j'en suis sûre d'avoir rempli leur
devoir mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils
se sentent soulagés ranucci n'a pas à
penser à la peine de mort lorsqu'il a
tué l'enfant sa tête si elle tombe ne
sera pas sans doute un meilleur exemple
après avoir entendu le premier éco du
couperet ce soir on se sent déchiré par
le meurtre de l'enfant et l'annoncent du
verdict
combien sont tranquilles ceux qui
pensent sincèrement que la peine de mort
et efficace juste exemplaires je les
envie
la maison
donnez aujourd'hui la parole aux
différents protagonistes de cette
affaire vous ne verrez pas pendant ce
journal d'extrait de ce film le pull
over rouge michel derache s'y opposent
afin justement de ménager les
susceptibilités de chacun
le réalisateur n'en est pas moins
aujourd'hui extrêmement surpris il l'a
confié il y à quelques instants en fin
de matinée à françois figement feeling
d'un livre le boulevard rouge et gilles
perrault qui n'a en tous cas librairie
c'est à dire que nous sommes pas on nous
parle souvent de moscou en me disant que
les événements circulent sous le manteau
et renault type et or ce livre est édité
vu les gens qui sont dans une question
dans ce livre porte leur vrai nom il n'y
a eu aucune action en justice contre ce
livre soudainement parce qu'on en fait
un film et que moi je prend la
précaution de changer le nom de tout le
monde sauf de ranucci ont créé un
événement justice et qui à mon avis est
déplorable parce qu'on utilise la
douleur de ses parents personne ne peut
se mettre à la place de ses parents qui
vivent une tragédie qui vivront toute
leur vie une tragédie évidemment et ce
serait hypocrite de dire que quelqu'un
peut penser ce qu'ils pensent mais il
faut penser peut-être que la faire
annuler chine a fait deux victimes
parce que la mère de ranucci on a quand
même coupé son fils en morceaux et l on
n'en parle jamais or s'il ya eu doute ou
si on peut faire quelque chose pour que
ce le la requête en révision de ce
procès soit né et soit jugé
et si mon film est la pierre qui fera
avancer les choses je suis très fier
d'avoir fait ce film est très fier de
passer en justice pour ça est ce que je
trouve aussi donnant c'est que j'ai 50
ans je n'ai jamais fait un film basé sur
le scandale c'est sûrement pas
maintenant que je vais commencer et le
scandale c'est d'essayer de faire une
affaire avait quelque chose avec une
douleur des parents
à votre avis pourquoi les parents
veulent t'ils interdire votre film
écoutez c'est difficile la semaine
dernière il décrit déclaré à l afp dans
les radios qu' il ne voulait pas que le
prénom de leur fille soit à présenter et
que leur nom soit évoqué or depuis on
leur a fait savoir qu'il n'a jamais été
question que leur nom et le nom de la
petite fille soit évoqué les noms sont
changés pour tout le monde
or maintenant je pense qu'ils disent est
attendu d'eux
la requête qu'ils ont contre moi ils
disent que c'est parce que leur petit
garçon de 10 ans peut être troublé par
le film c'est vrai mais que 20 milliards
110 on peut ne pas voir un film je pense
et puis quand le ce petit garçon de 10
ans voit par exemple ce qui se passe au
cambodge où les images nous a montré
hier les enfants maintenant sont
troublés et vivent leurs heures de notre
vie présente et puis je m'épate aussi
parce que imaginer que les parents de la
victime de jean-marie de vaud de ce fait
interdit un livre qui a eu lieu est
interdit tout le processus de justice
qui a amené une requête une révision de
son procès jean-marie de vaud serait
encore en prison
et alors pour remonter plus loin si
personne n'avait pensé de la justice
s'était trompé dreyfus encore à l'île du
diable et madame ranucci dans cette
affaire quelle est sa réaction
madame radio si elle est probablement
aussi bouleversé parce qu'on remue on
rouvre un dossier elle n'a pas vu le
film je pense mais je veux dire elle
elle sait que l'on va éclairer les zones
d'ombré qui ont condamné son fils alors
ce qui est aussi bizarre c'est que dans
le dans le livre comme dans le film on
ne dit pas ghannouchi était innocent ont
dit ils étaient peut-être innocent il
était peut-être coupable il ya des zones
d'ombré des deux côtés c'est l'évidence
mais ce qu'on démontre c'est la façon
dont ça s'est passé
et qu'en aucun cas je pense on a pu tous
qu'ils étaient pour son innocence a été
escamoté et le film c'est de raconter
aux citoyens aux français comment ça
peut se passer dans un cas évidemment ça
se passe pas toujours comme ça mais là
c'est un cas type est un cas désespéré
parce que yahoo lui aussi mort d'homme
alors ensemble votre film comme le livre
de gilles perrault dit il y a peut-être
eu erreur judiciaire
absolument
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie de
faire ce film vous étiez un partisan
militant contre la peine de mort
militant c'est difficile à dire non
jeunes militants non mais je suis un
partisan vraiment forcené de l'abolition
parce que je trouve que c'est quand même
invraisemblable de penser que la france
et la grèce qui ont été à chacun leur
moment d'effarement civilisations sont
les deux seuls pays d'europe où la peine
de mort est maintenu c'est quand même
grave parce que dans les autres pays il
n'ya pas une criminalité plus grande
part ce n'est pas la peine de mort
or la peine de mort c'est un assassinat
on assassine quelqu'un
révision du procès de christian ranucci
guillotiné il ya cinq ans pour le
meurtre d'un enfant a peut-être de
nouvelles chances d'aboutir une enquête
est en effet actuellement menée par un
haut fonctionnaire de la police et
pourrait faire ressortir des faits
nouveaux
les précisions de paul lefebvre
christian ranucci vous le savez a été
condamné et exécuté le 28 juillet 76
pour avoir assassiné le 3 juin 74 une
petite fille de 8 ans qui s'appelait
maria dolorès rambla il avait toujours
protesté de son innocence
au cours du procès mais il faut se
rappeler qu'il avait avoué deux fois la
première fois devant les policiers du
srpj de marseille et la seconde fois
devant le juge d'instruction qui avait
conduit l'information ce dossier et d'un
dossier très difficile pour ma part je
considère qu'il ya autant d'éléments de
culpabilité que deux zones de doute
l'instruction de l'affairé douchy vous
souvenez sans doute a été très rapide et
surtout mené sous la pression de
l'opinion publique
le procès à aix également a été
difficile avec la foule qui criait à
mort dans la salle et autour du palais
justice text me souviens très bien
j'étais il ya dans la procédure c'est
vrai un certain nombre d'irrégularités
et aujourd'hui une demande de révision
est présenté par les deux avocats de
ranucci maître jean denis bredin et
jean-françois le forcené cette demande
de révision est appuyée sur deux
éléments d'abord concernant les av
on s'est aperçu que quelques lignes
avaient été ajoutés au dessus de la
signature de se radoucit sur le
procès-verbal d'aveux et on ne sait pas
très bien qui a écrit ces quelques
lignes
deuxième élément là il concerne ça
concerne un témoignage la veille du
meurtre ghannouchi aurait eu une
altercation à marseille avec quelqu'un
et ce quelqu'un a été retrouvée en août
il avait toujours parlé de cette visite
à marseille la veille du meurtre et il
avait dit qu'il était ivre et le
témoignage de
de cette personne confiant les policiers
ont toujours repousser cette déclaration
de ranucci en prétendant qu'il se
trouvait à salers masse étaient ces
moments là et cette déclaration était
liée d'une certaine manière la thèse de
l'innocence pour l'instant une contre
enquête est menée par le commissaire
divisionnaire le bruchec et ses
résultats seront examinés et là c'est
une procédure nouvelle par une
commission composée des représentants de
la chancellerie des avocats de ranucci
et de l'avocat de la famille de la
petite fille m pironi de toulon
la conclusion les conclusions de cette
commission seront ensuite proposés au
garde des sceaux qui s'il le juge utile
transmettra le dossier à la cour de
cassation
en pologne un mois après la proclamation
de l'état
christian ranucci condamnés à mort et
exécutés en 76 sera-t-il rejugé la
commission de révision de la cour de
cassation s'est réuni ce matin
elle rendra sa décision dans une
quinzaine de jours rappel des faits
clément weill-raynal christian ranucci
lors de son arrestation en juin 1974
le jeune homme connu pour son caractère
fragile vient d'avouer aux policiers
être l'assassin de la petite maria
dolorès rambla dont le corps a été
retrouvé quelques jours auparavant dans
une carrière au dessus de marseille
plus tard au cours de l'instruction
ranucci se rétracte mais la machine
judiciaire est enclenchée ranucci sera
condamné à mort puis guillotiné en
juillet 1976
depuis maintenant quinze ans la famille
et les amis de christian ranucci demande
régulièrement la révision du procès pour
la défense la condamnation de christian
ranucci en dépit de ses aveux est une
effroyable erreur judiciaire
de nombreuses pièces du dossier négligée
lors du procès innocenterait le jeune
homme des témoins essentiels auraient
été oubliés des procès verbaux
surchargées des pièces à conviction
comme le fameux pull-over rouge aurait
été mal exploité la décision de la cour
de cassation de réviser ou non le procès
sera connue dans une quinzaine de jours
et la colère ni self
9 octobre
trouve un la peine de mort est abolie en
france un engagement de la gauche qui
allait à l'encontre de la majorité des
français à l'époque avant d'en parler
avec robert badinter
retour sur une des affaires qui a
provoqué le débat dans les années 70
l'exécution de crise en ranucci alors
que le doute sur sa culpabilité n'a
jamais été levé
marité recours tellement le dossier est
resté sur le bureau de m le forsonney
pourtant la sphère date de 1974 l'avocat
avait alors 25 ans ranucci était son
premier client était commis d'office
comme personne ne voulait assurer sa
défense
il fallait bien que quelqu'un s'y colle
donc le sort est tombé sur moi accepter
la défense
un matin du mois de juin il y à 27 ans
la cité sainte agnès à marseille une
petite fille marie dolorès rambla est
enlevée par un homme décrit par deux
témoins comme étant jeune brun grand et
mince
une heure plus tard un automobiliste
brûle un stop à la sortie de marseille
le conducteur percute un autre véhicule
avant de s'enfuir deux témoins le
prennent en chasse relève son numéro
d'immatriculation avant de le voir
partir dans ces fours et un paquet
volumineux sous le bras le soir même
christian ranucci est arrêté après 18
heures d'interrogatoire il avoue
l'enlèvement et le meurtre de marie
dolorès indique même où il a caché
l'armé du crime
des charges sont accablantes mais quinze
jours plus tard l'homme revient sur ses
aveux il accuse la police de l'avoir
obligé à parler le 10 mars 76
christian ranucci et condamné à mort à
l'énoncé de la sentence le public
applaudit pourtant le dossier présente
des failles avec notamment le mystère du
bulot vert rouge retrouvé sur les lieux
du crime
après l'avoir flairer les chiens sont
allés jusqu'au corps de la petite fille
c'est prouvé ce pull n'appartenait pas à
christian ranucci le doute ne profitera
pas à l'accusé valéry giscard d'estaing
refuse à grasse le 28 juillet christian
ranucci est décapité on s'est retrouvés
à la maison d'arrêt à 4 heures du matin
où il y avait pour éviter de faire du
bruit et de prévenir le reste de la
maison grise à versailles et couvertures
par terre pour marche dans le silence
j'avais une lettre de sa mère je le lui
ouais c'est le dernier regard que j'ai
eus drame ou chez mon très cher enfant
je t'écris cette carte que tu es avocat
te donneront en claquettes à grasse soit
refusé tu es innocent et tu as été un
bon fils criton innocence soit courageux
pense à moi je t'embrasse fort ta maman
moi j'ai pas de peine à reconnaître que
j'ai pas regardé ça mais tu guillotine
ce sont les bruits c'est assez le bruit
l'espèce de joux qui descend claque
comme ça sur la tête le bruit du couteau
et gedo alors voilà les souvenirs qu'on
garde de ça sont des bruits 25 ans plus
tard un autre homme n'a pas oublié ce
matin du 28 juillet 1976
nous avons rencontré pierre grimblat le
père de la petite fille assassinée
maintenant que ces moments les criminels
de ta fille il est plus une un coupé la
tête
alors là ils étaient soulagés il faut
maintenant il a tué ma fille il y aura
plus personne
voilà c'est important c'est la faute à
monaco chaque année et chaque fois
qu'apple avait la faire en gestion ou
puyol général avec eux et pour moi je
crois que c'est ma fille la coupable de
la mort d'un jeune chercheur à peu près
propre et 25 ans plus tard mettre le
forsonney s'interroge toujours qu'ils
étaient réellement responsable de cette
sentence de mort quelqu'un meurt mais la
responsabilité de cette mort est à la
fois collective diluée et insaisissable
est ce que c'est la faute de l'avocat
qui a mal défendu
général qui a requis
est ce que c'est la faute du juge qui a
mal jugé est-ce que sa faute de
l'opinion publique
soyez faut des accusés qui avoue oui
enfin c'est cette si vous me demandez un
souvenir bon jeu gentil repartons
plusieurs rouge dit voilà c'est ça qui
est frappant à trois reprises depuis
l'exécution de christian ranucci cet
avocat a déposé une requête en révision
du procès à trois reprises
la justice française l'a dégoûté